earlier I reiterated that despite the
maneuvers the Texans made over the
weekend I'm still gonna stick with the
Indianapolis Colts winning the AFC South
I'm not gonna waver from that even
though the Texans now are much better
than they were when I made that
prediction on Friday Laremy Tunsil one
of the best if not the best young tackle
in the league is now gonna be protecting
- Shawn Watson who has Kenny Stills
along with will fuller to take the top
of a defense off with DeAndre Hopkins
and now as well they've got they've got
some momentum going into the season I
guess in an addition by subtraction one
would think with Jadeveon Clowney out I
gave the the half glass full look at the
way the Texans made their maneuvers over
the weekend so also with Justin
Verlander calling in an hour number
three of the show after his no-hitter
with the Astros we figured we have got
to get our buddy from Houston back here
on the show to help us kick off our NFL
100 week and that is a man in his 43rd
year covering the NFL for the Houston
Chronicle also could be heard on sports
radio 610 in Houston and 104.5 the zone
in Nashville he's all over the spot his
name is John McLane how are you John I'm
excited this season is just so wide open
and we talked about it with Chris Carter
in the the first part of our show it's
so tough to predict what can happen this
year because we hardly saw a lick of
significant preseason football and then
things obviously change from year to
year I wondering how somebody who's
covered this for 43 years sees it
rich the coaches have made a sham out of
the preseason I believe and the new CBA
will have two more regular season games
which they wanted dad will see more
joint practices we'll see I'm guessing
the coaches will want players more in
the offseason and I believe the owners
are willing to give them a lot of
concessions like an insurance benefits
page I'd want free agency a year sooner
if I were the players because the owners
as you know rich are going to make a
fortune going to two more regular-season
games from networks from streaming and
the players want that piece of the five
but I don't think we will ever see for
preseason is again preseason games when
I started rich there were six and
training camp was eight weeks long huh
so now can you get a sense at all though
of who's good and who's not I mean but
that's I guess my my question right now
predicting who's gonna win it all John
what about you every year rich in The
Chronicle football section I think the
Patriots and more often than not I'm
right now they suffered a lot of losses
as we all know but as long as bail check
and Brady are there I'm thinking the
Patriots so a big New Orleans in the NFC
I think it is a top-heavy League not one
dominant team but they're quite a few
good ones at the Rams Kansas City
Indianapolis I thought was I do not
anymore without Andrew Luck I'm not as
sold on Jacoby Brazil as some are even
though he's three and O against the
Texans we call him the Texan the killer
want to know with New England - no with
Indian 2017 so I think it's going to be
a fun season the two teams I'm looking
the most bored watching rich the
Cleveland Browns of love to see for the
Cleveland fans and my love
suffering friends in the media you to
have the Browns be legitimate playoff
team another one is the Oakland Raiders
I never missed an edition of hard knocks
see them all I can't wait to see how the
John graden soap opera plays out John
McClain of the Houston Chronicle here on
the Rich Eisen show let's get into the
big moves that Bill O'Brien essentially
haunch out for this organization over
the weekend the general sense of things
John nationally is that short term it's
a big maneuver to get that offensive
line anchored with Tunsil and obviously
stills can help offensively with this
team however to give the price up that
they gave without signing Tunsil to a
long-term contract and giving away
clowny four cents on the dollar while
also spending multiple millions
themselves they sent him to Seattle long
term this is a head scratcher I'm
wondering what you think John McClain
Bill O'Brien is in charge he's the
general manager without the title he's
got the unto him that he delegates to
but he negotiates the trades he decides
who he wants on the roster Cal McNair
the owner signs off on the finances like
throwing in seven million to Seattle to
pay for the clowny franchise tender so
they want to win now the offensive
players are ecstatic to get time sold to
get Kenny Stills 16 yards average for
care attention his career 21 touchdowns
the last three years
a genuine deep threat with will fuller
opposite DeAndre Hopkins they added
Carlos Hyde in the backfield they lost
them are Miller tides average 832 yards
over the last three years
he'll complement Duke Johnson who huge
Sean Watson is really pumped about
because he's averaged more than nine
yards of catching his career with a
brown but defensively they're not going
to be as good at heavy on clowny great
one player good pass rusher and they
can't replace it and the starter in the
lineup opposite Whitney merciless
brennon scarlet in his fourth year that
gave him an extension last week they
added depth and outside linebacker that
they did not have in the Seattle trade
and they got the best they can do rich
because they backed themselves into a
corner they should have traded clown he
signed him and then traded him because
the Seahawks essentially are going to
have him for one season playing for
three defensive in on the weak side
which is his natural position and then
he's probably going to go somewhere
where they got a lot of Catherine a lot
more than the Seahawks and pay him a lot
of money and it would be interesting
here if Chris Ballard in Indianapolis
who has more chat room than anybody if
he didn't step up and make an
uncultivated
then we get to see him play the Texans
slicing their doesn't think a whole lot
of fun so right now the defense is not
as good rich the offense is better
players don't care about those drafts
they don't care about the seven million
jabbing they're included in that deal
they want to win now well what about
what would you say John McLean of this
is exactly why you don't let a head
coach be your general manager also
because the general manager should look
down the road and and and and be
somebody who manages generally as
opposed to when right here right now
like a coach would need that's what
that's what general managers are
supposed to do in bill O'Brien's case
people are saying he's trying to save
his job no it's the first year of the
four-year extension Bill O'Brien to me
would have to have two losing records in
a row to be fired and as long as he's
got Watson and quarterback they're going
to be in every game rich Watson has not
lost a game by more than one score in
his two seasons he's kept them in every
single game so I think they're going to
have to score a lot of points I think
they will play a lot of high-scoring
games and win the 2021 draft rolls
around and they don't have picks in the
first two rounds they're going to have
to do like they did last year
when they drafted guys like Justin
reading Tiki cutie players like that
when they didn't have things in the
first two rounds John McClane the
Houston Chronicle here on the Rich Eisen
show and walk me again through how it
does work so Bill O'Brien essentially is
the one on the phone who is talking to
John Schneider of Seattle who is talking
to to the Dolphins to make these deals
and then hands it off to somebody else
and is there any does he have to go to
the McNair family and get a a checkmark
on these things how how does it work
John
Bill O'Brien is God people Jack Easter B
he runs football ops and has got his
fingerprints on everything in personnel
Matt vasgersian who is the director of
player personnel is involved crystals
and their longtime cap expert contract
negotiators all those guys are involved
but O'Brien finalizes the deal if it's
into toxic al McNair every day to let
him know what he's doing and why are you
doing it and if it's something like that
7 million McNair has to sign off on it I
mean there's I've never let money stand
in the way of decisions and so that's
the way they operate if it doesn't work
they hire a general manager after the
season yeah because I mean if to make
this trade to give up so much for Tunsil
and then not to sign him long term
before you trade I mean you've just
basically given this guy the store and
we're seeing guys with leverage take
advantage of it and I think rightfully
so of players all over the map from Zeke
- obviously clowny
why wouldn't Tunsil ask for literally
the moon knowing that there's no way the
Texans don't give it to him because of
how much they gave up for him why I
believe Johnson will become the
highest-paid offensive lineman in
history they could pick up his fifth
year option they also could if they
wanted to franchise in two years after
that but they liked the guy Bill O'Brien
likes him he traded for him they'll sign
him and Jimmy Sexton his agents got to
be salivating at the money he's going to
get from the
Jaxon's when he signs that extension so
are you pleased about this John do you
think this is the right move for the
Texans shoulda played which I thought
they should have brought back cloudy
this season he went to a pass rushing
Academy to try to get ten sacks for the
first time in his career he did it with
Julius Peppers and Chuck Smith in Miami
where he worked out when he wasn't in
Houston I thought they should have
brought him back then trade him before
the draft and I also signed him to a
long-term deal or let another team sign
him to a long-term deal and I think that
would have been the prudent way to do it
that way the defense would still be
really good and then give up whatever
you want for console and stills because
today when you trade number one fakes
and you think you're going to be good
you think right or wrong they're going
to be in the 20s and with free agency
you can family cap right you can spend
money in free agency but they're still
getting roasted O'Brien is over not
getting enough for clowny giving up too
much for Laremy Tunsil and Kenny Stills
so then before I just turn the page a
little bit to Justin Verlander or
anything Astros because I have him on in
our number three I give you the ability
to put your your mark or the John
McClane marker on this football team in
the state of Texas as the future the
ones that are gonna win a championship
perhaps not this year but beyond or
certainly beyond more I'll give you both
obviously NFL teams and I also give you
am and you t John and I know you're a
Baylor guy but which one do you put
which one do you put on the state of
Texas I think this team is going to be
sustainably excellent
I think both of them will be sustainably
excellent but I think Thom Hartmann has
got the University of Texas back to
where Texas used to be and I think
they'll become a top ten program every
year maybe a top five
I think the Longhorns will be in the
championship game against Oklahoma and I
think that when they play during the
season it's going to be another
incredible game I think University of
Texas is back as a Baylor alum that
pains me I'm glad that Dana Holgorsen
left West Virginia for Houston because
West Virginia feet up on my bears all
the time but in am am is in the wrong
division in the SEC but the nm is always
good and exciting and Jimbo Fisher has
done a tremendous job so far and I think
based on recruiting will continue to do
it and then the Cowboys are going to be
good again
Texans beat them in overtime last year
so the Texans can brag for the next four
years as far as the Texans rich I'll
tell you something I've never said in 43
years of covering unit bill and Houston
I believe
deshaun Watson will win a Super Bowl I
don't know the goats will be might be
Bill O'Brien might be some someone else
but I believe Watson is a great young
quarterback and if this receivers
besides Hopkins stay healthy and the
offensive line improves the way we think
it will I believe Watson at some point
is going to bring his first Super Bowl
into Houston just like Justin Verlander
ignited the Astros first World Series
run in 2017 that is quite something
right there John and Verlander over the
weekend it seems like when something
like this happens at the outset of
September that is a great way to just
get the juices flowing for an October
that I'm sure Houston fans are very much
looking forward to same record as the
Yankees right now and everyone's
assuming they're gonna take on each
other in the ALCS I wonder what you
think of Verlander having seen Nolan
Ryan
in front of you and and I know putting
him in that company is quite a mouthful
but there's only six human beings in the
history of Major League Baseball to have
three or more no-hitters and now
Verlander joins that group with NOLA
it's been an unbelievable time with
Verlander after that trade to think how
late it went right up till the last
minute and he and Kate Upton had to
discuss it right up to the last minute
and you know these happy as can be
especially when you look it's what
happened to the Tigers Verlander is
beloved here he's this I think the
second best pitcher they've ever had -
Nolan Ryan Ryan is his hero as what as
role model his idol and Nolan is there
an awful lot and what Verlander does he
is must-see TV even though I covered the
Texans I'm a die-hard Astros fan and
what there's two things I do rich he
pitches I drop whatever I'm doing to
watch and the other one is their their
new power hitting your Don Alvarez if
you've not seen Alvarez this kid is
amazing I dropped what I'm doing when he
comes to bat and I can't wait for the
playoffs and I think you're right
Yankees versus Astros both teams as foes
that better starting pitching Yankees
have a better bullpen most astro fans
will tell you right now rich they're I'm
doing if they don't win they won't get
to the World Series and weights will be
their bullpen John you take care of
yourself man I always love our chats
I mean Houston has found itself in the
center of the sports universe more often
than ever before we didn't even hit on
the Rockets which who are gonna be back
in action starting next year to stay by
the phone man it's it's amazing how
Houston keeps going getting stuck to
right front and center like it was this
weekend always be on with you I'm always
honored thank you very much and have fun
see you - John McClane that's John
McClane of the Houston Chronicle also of
Sports radio's 610 there in Houston
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show
tuned to audience channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app